Most Disney movies are all sweetness and light,
right?
Sure, there are moments of tragedy - Bambi's
mother being shot and Simba's father falling
to his death reduced EVERYONE who witnessed
them to tears - but, in general, the movies
are all 100% child-friendly.
Or so they seem on the surface.
But there are actually some theories that
turn some Disney movies into terribly dark
affairs.
Interpreting these movies in such twisted
ways might seem a little morbid, but it's
actually pretty fun and intriguing, so we've
made a video about it!
We hope you enjoy it - and please make sure
you subscribe to our channel so you can keep
coming back to watch more like it.
Here are ten Disney theories that turn into
the darkest movies ever.
Up
2009's Up is such a heartwarming movie.
Its three main characters are two cranky old
men and a nervous little kid, which is so
unlike most movies these days - but it's wonderful.
However, it doesn't seem so wonderful if one
of those characters is actually dead, does
it?
Yeah, we're getting off to a gloomy start
here, because this theory suggest that Up's
Carl Fredricksen is actually deceased, having
passed away in his sleep after he was told
he'd be forced to live in a retirement home.
It actually makes a lot of sense too.
It suggests that the movie is Carl's journey
through the afterlife, with young Russell
being his guardian angel - one who is attempting
to earn his wings by guiding Carl through
his transition.
Furthermore, Russell taking the form of a
child was to fulfill Carl and Ellie’s desire
to have children, the house in the movie is
symbolic of Carl’s attachment to the physical
world, and Paradise Falls is Carl’s idea
of Heaven.
Interesting, right?
But you haven't heard anything yet...
Aladdin
So...
Aladdin.
You're probably thinking it's set centuries
in the past, right?
Well yeah, it probably is, but there's a pretty
damn dark and disturbing theory that suggests
it might not be.
The 1992 movie, of course, features the Genie
of the Lamp - voiced so wonderfully by the
late, great Robin Williams - and he makes
reference to a number of modern movies and
celebrities.
Now, given that he was supposed to have been
trapped in a lamp for thousands of years - and
given the supposed time setting of the story
regardless of that - that shouldn't be possible.
I mean, how would he know of those references?
Well, the theory we mentioned suggests that
Aladdin is actually set thousands of years
in future, in a post-apocalyptic wasteland,
after a world-ending disaster that set mankind
back by milennia.
Nice, huh?
WALL-E
What a nice, friendly, harmless little robot
WALL-E was.
The star of the 2008 movie wouldn't hurt a
fly and the only evil robot to come out of
Buy-N-Large was AUTO, right?
Well, we'd like to think so, but one extremely
dark theory actually suggests that WALL-E
is responsible for the entire destruction
of Earth!
Yikes!
We saw him happily cannibalising parts from
another model he found, adding it to his delightful
collection of spare parts.
But he also has a trailer full of parts.
Just how many other models did he tear to
pieces?
Definitely alot more than he required to run.
These were trophies from his previous kills!
Bearing in mind WALL-E had been around for
approximately 700 years, that 700-year-long
killing spree gradually wiped out the rest
of the recycling robots!
It explains why the planet looked like a total
dump and why he's the only robot around.
He literally destroyed Earth!
Wreck-It Ralph
This is less of a theory and more something
that fans have decuced ACTUALLY HAPPENED,
but it's not something you immediately think
of and it definitely puts a much darker edge
on one aspect of 2012's Wreck-It Ralph.
One of the movie's main characters - Sergeant
Tamora Jean Calhoun - has a tragic backstory
in that she watched her husband-to-be get
eaten by a Cy-bug, just seconds before they
were due to marry, then killed the Cy-bug
in question.
That's bad enough, but fans have pointed out
that Cy-bugs assimilate their victims and
BECOME them, meaning Calhoun would've had
to kill a murderous insectoid version of the
man she loved.
No wonder she was sometimes crabby!
The Little Mermaid
There's a neat theory that suggests Disney's
The Little Mermaid, Frozen, Tangled and Tarzan
are all set within the same universe.
We won't go into why here - that's not the
"dark" part of this entry - but just believe
us when we say it's true.
The dark part comes because of what that means
for 1989's The Little Mermaid in particular.
The aforementioned theory suggests that the
parents of Frozen's Elsa and Anna died at
sea on the way to Rapunzel and Flynn's wedding,
which would place their watery graves near
Denmark.
That means the wreck from which Ariel scrounges
human artefacts to satisfy her weird obsession
is Elsa and Anna's parents ship - and Ariel
was graverobbing from and desecrating the
decaying corpses of a nice couple who perished
en route to a wedding.
Frozen
Speaking of Frozen, the 2013 movie was - and
remains - an incredibly popular movie.
In fact, it's the highest-grossing animated
movie of all time.
Everybody loved it - especially children - but
we're not sure the kids would be so fond of
it if they believed a pretty dark theory that
is doing the rounds about it!
The heroic Kristoff seemed like a nice guy,
right?
Well this theory suggests that the guy's clothes
point to reindeer murder!
The indigenous Sami people are known for wearing
reindeer hide and the likelihood is that the
ice harvesters killed a reindeer and gave
its pelt to Kristoff to keep warm.
Here's where it gets really dark.
This theory explains why Sven the reindeer
is so attached to Kristoff - the guy is wearing
what remains of his dead mother.
Peter Pan
1953's Peter Pan really is a quintessential
Disney classic.
In the movie, the titular boy has a mischievous
shadow with which he has a rather fun and
playful relationship - but one dark theory
suggests that there might be a sinister tale
behind the shadow, and that it's actually
a lot to do with dark magic.
The theory is that Peter's shadow is a window
into hell and an extension of himself - notice
how it was able to touch and move things?
For reference, Dr. Facilier's shadow in another
Disney movie - The Princess and the Frog - could
do the same thing, and he ended up being dragged
to hell after making a deal with the devil.
Could Peter have made a similar deal?
It seems unlikely, but when you consider that
it might have been in exchange for his eternal
life, it starts to make sense.
Let's just hope Peter keeps his side of whatever
bargain he made with Satan!
Partysaurus Rex
Although it's not a full feature picture,
2012's Partysaurus Rex - a spin-off from the
Toy Story movies - is indeed a short film,
so we feel happy to include it here.
The theory about it, however, is more based
on the Monsters, Inc. movies - and it suggests
that poor Sulley has been turned into a toilet
seat cover!
You may remember a quote from Monsters, Inc.
in which Randall Boggs says "I heard humans
skin monsters and make toilet covers out of
their fur."
Well, look at the toilet seat in Partysaurus
Rex!
That's Sulley!
He's been skinned and turned into a toilet
seat cover!
No wonder there was no sequel to Monsters,
Inc. - its star character is most likely dead!
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
We're going back a long way now - pre-World
War II, in fact - to 1937 and Snow White and
the Seven Dwarves.
Given just how creepy this theory is, there's
absolutely no way we could have left it out.
You know how the Prince in the movie is...
well... the quintessential Prince Charming?
Well what if he wasn't?
What if he was actually Death itself?
The theory suggests that the kiss he gave
Snow White to revive her actually sent her
to the afterlife.
It stems largely from American Horror Story:
Asylum, in which the Angel of Death's method
for sending people to the other side was to
kiss them and suck the life out of them.
Snow White saying her goodbyes to the dwarves
looked like she was being led off to a fairytale
ending - but what if she was waving goodbye
to them for all eternity?
Creepy, right?
Moreover, the Prince has a white horse.
Revelations 6:8 states "I looked, and there
before me was a pale horse!
Its rider was named Death."
The Incredibles
You probably remember the "no capes" scene,
from 2004's The Incredibles, when Edna Mode
tells Mr. Incredible on about all the past
superheroes who died because their capes got
caught in things like vortexes and missiles.
And you probably remember Stratogale getting
sucked into a plane engine by her cape.
Well there's a very dark side to all of that.
Not only was Stratogale a mere schoolkid,
making her death all the more tragic, the
likelihood is that her death caused a plane
crash, killing hundreds of civilian passengers.
Remember how the movies tells of superheroes
going into hiding because of the collateral
damage they caused?
That all makes sense now, right?
Furthermore, Edna designed Stratogale's suit,
so she probably blames herself, and a dark
theory suggests that she did the same for
the evil Syndrome and purposely included a
cape in his ensemble in order to potentially
get him killed as a way of making amends.
Thanks for watching our video about ten Disney
theories that turn into the darkest movies
ever.
What other theories have you heard that make
Disney movies seem a lot darker than they
do on the surface?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.